son élaboration avait débuté avant la
fusion alors que saint quentin en
yvelines était à cette commune un plan
local d'urbanisme intercommunal qui
nécessitent d'être révisé de petites
modifications avant l'élaboration dans
un second temps d'un nouveau paix lui à
12 dont la réflexion pourrait commencer
en 2021
il ya très peu de modifications puisque
c'est une révision allégé donc les trois
grands axes du pays et lui l'économie
générale du produit lui tout est prêt à
être préservée c'est vraiment des
modifications d'écriture réglementaire
des modifications de zonage à la marge
c'est là l'augmentation de protection
patrimoniale sur sur certains secteurs
et puis la préservation amendé centre et
hameaux ont été identifiés comme un peu
fragile après une présentation les
habitants pouvaient échanger avec les
urbanistes autour des cartes et des
documents de cette première ébauche de
paix lui
les habitants doivent connaître les
évolutions de leur propre territoire de
façon à pouvoir amener leurs pierres et
leurs remarques
on peut aussi avoir oublié des choses
ont bien les habitants peuvent ne pas
être d'accord avec les évolutions dont
propose donc c'est un moment très
dispensable
l'objectif est d'arrêter le projet pour
le conseil communautaire du 27 juin
s'enchaînera une consultation des
personnes publiques associées
puis une enquête publique pour son
approbation en janvier 2020 c'est des
choses
voyez qu'on n'a pas forcément
dont on n'a pas forcément accès dans la
vie quotidienne et qu'une réunion
publique permet de
d'apporter de deux mois j'étais
intéressé parce qu'en fait ma maison et
se trouve classée donc elle maintenant
elle est protégée par ce nouveau pays
chaque habitant peut faire part de ses
remarques dans les registres des hôtels
de ville 17 communes en écrivant
président de l'agglomération ou bien en
envoyant un mail à l'adresse
spécialement créée